MARK SHOTLAND: Greetings from
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
My name is Mark Shotland.
I'm the director of training at the
Abdul Latif Jameel Poverty Action Lab.
The Jameel Poverty Action Lab,
or J-PAL, is a research center
in the Economics Department
of The Massachusetts
Institute of Technology, MIT.
J-PAL has been offering an
executive education course
on evaluating social
programs since 2005.
So we'll be coming up on the tenth
run of this course this year.
We've also offered this course about
30 other times, across the globe,
leveraging our regional offices
in South Asia, Europe, Africa,
and Southeast Asia.
So, I would like to welcome you to
the online version of course hosted
by MITx, part of the edX consortium.
J-PAL's Evaluating
Social Program course is
targeted for policymakers
and practitioners
from governments, NGOs, international
aid agencies, foundations,
and other donors.
And basically, it's purpose for
them-- if you're part of this group,
it's purpose is to
help give you the tools
to distinguish good
evidence from bad evidence,
assuming you want to incorporate
evidence into your decision making
process.
It should also help you
identify opportunities
for when to do an evaluation and
how to do an evaluation, assuming
you want to evaluate your
own programs and policies.
It's also targeted to academics and
evaluators who are looking to retool.
Particularly, the
focus of this course is
on impact evaluation
and a particular kind
of impact evaluation,
randomized valuations
or randomized controlled trials.
So, I would like to welcome you to edX.
Welcome you to J-PAL 101x,
Evaluating Social Programs.